hi i'm alvin welcome back to tasty's
making it big where we make
giant versions of some of america's most
beloved foods
today i'm going to be making a giant
boba milk tea drink
but the thing is i've never made boba
from scratch so i'm going to call my
friend inka she was my co-host on the
giant ramen episode
and i think it's going to be a lot of
fun so enough talk and let's get started
[Music]
what's up inka how's it going alvin good
we are using
your bubble recipe today to make a giant
boba i'm going to get started so
first thing is the the sugar in the
water right okay stir it until it gets
dissolved
right yeah wait what heat should i be
cooking this on
basically just enough for the sugar to
melt you don't want it to be on high
heat
do you have it on high heat that was on
height yikes
yeah basically once it's warm you'll
want to remove it from the heat actually
remove it the starch
sorry table that one tablespoon full
that's a lot that's
a little bit less okay it's like that
yeah sure
all right she said it so if the recipe
goes wrong it's not my fault
you know i can only see so much from the
zoo oh that's true
it's 100 my fault as you're stirring it
right it should form into like almost
like a paste
that's great once it's all dissolved you
want to return it to the heat and now
you just cook it down
until it's slightly thicker okay return
to the heat wow it's like three
ingredients but
the amount of like technique is quite a
lot i think it's getting kind of thick
now
the rest of this starch goes in and then
stir fast
oh it's getting sticky oh boy like
really lumpy
it's like really hard to scrape off the
bottom of the pan yo how do i know when
to
get it out you're supposed to get it out
like asap
oh okay asap all right so far
things are going bad
dude that's really liquidy it's your
recipe yo
like can you work with this do you think
so i think so i can't feel it so
yeah i mean it feels like oh god okay it
looks really weird right now so i'm not
gonna
i don't know how to describe this
texture uh
it's a little sticky and it's kind of
warm what the heck
it's kind of like alive the moment you
set it down it like does its own thing
but when you try to move it it's like a
rock wait okay then i think there's
something wrong
what's wrong it's not supposed to be
like a rock
yo i don't think that's right when
you're putting the starch in it
remember how like for you it was just
like a liquid it's supposed to
be like a dough at that point already
yeah no like it comes right off right
that's not right
when you pull it it should be stretchy
at this point stretchy
i think we have to redo it alvin oh no
it's 100
my fault it's okay it's only a few
ingredients it'll be okay
we'll be right back uh attempt number
two
you were saying that i messed up in the
sauce like the thick sauce stage we
think that's what it is that you need to
get it to
a consistency of a thick mochi sauce and
hopefully
that's the problem thick mochi sauce
thick mochi sauce thick mochi sauce
can you see this is that almost there
right no
it's not oh keep going ah that's where
that was the issue i think the first
time i didn't make the thick mochi sauce
it was just
sauce oh yeah i think it's good
are you 100 sure i'll take the blame you
can i'm like
85 80. oh that's a b
75 okay let's add the start okay off
heat right
yeah okay are you worried oh a hundred
percent
let's go for it okay she said go for it
please work does it feel different oh it
feels so different oh my god
like nothing's really getting stuck yes
yes yes yes yeah
so now what you have to do is roll it
out a little bit into like an oval shape
divide it into three sections okay you
need to wrap plastic around
two of the doughs this is just to help
retain its
moisture okay what's next what's next
roll this one out
into like a long snake shape until it's
like
roughly around 0.5 you have a ruler with
you
yeah i do 0.5 is actually still too big
it should be a little smaller
like a finger like a finger okay yeah
look at that little ball oh that looks
so nice
yes it looks great
boba has a pretty unique texture when
cooked how do you describe what it
tastes like or feels like
well the taste is faintly sweet but the
texture is
q-q q-q so q-q is the term that people
in taiwan use to describe the texture
when it's kind of chewy it has a slight
bounce to it but it's not rubbery i feel
like there's a misconception there
mochi is kind of qq you know like it's
that kind of a situation and qq is my
favorite word to describe everything
noodles can also be qq when they're
cooked
right i have currently rolled only this
much
yeah oh my god thanks nina for helping
me good luck alvin i'm sorry i can't be
there to help
i have a lot of work to do i'm gonna be
here for like hours do jesus
okay we're back in the tasty kitchen
with a huge pot the boiling water for
the tea
these are black tea bags these are the
ones that i use and i used to make and
sell bubble milk tea i'll tell you guys
that story later
but essentially you would just take
these tea bags and drop it in
and we have 500 tea bags
sounds like a lot that's because it is i
think this might have enough caffeine
to keep an elephant going for a very
very long time
all right so this is all the tea it's
been chilled it's been brewed
as you can tell the color is super
intense it gets like
22 liters or so i don't know how many
cups of boba that's gonna make but i
think the answer is
a lot
okay after many hours and some culinary
assistance we were able to make a lot of
fresh
boba four trays probably like a thousand
of these little ones all right here we
go oh they're like little
little bullets oh wow this is really hot
all right let's give these a stir one
more
here we go oh this is burning don't kill
yourself alvin
come on that was pretty nice aninka's
recipe the goal is to cook these until
the bobas rise to the surface
goodbye you little boba balls
all these little bobas they're nice and
plump
so i'm going to take these guys directly
into some ice water i think i said this
stuff is really important because it
sort of shocks the outside
of the boba and helps to give it that qq
texture that she was talking about
they look really good and they can't
stay in the ice water for too long
wow look at that that's awesome
okay i have a lot of little boba balls
to cook so
see you guys in a bit pretty important
part about boba
at least for me is if it has like a nice
brown sugar syrup and to start five cups
of water
into this giant pot and
seven and a half cups of dark brown
sugar
stir this until everything comes
together you sort of have
this syrupy brown sugar that's really
nice and i've coached the outside
of the cup and i kind of make this
streaky pattern probably my favorite
part
is going to be cooking the boba in it so
here we go
stir until it gets nice and sticky and
sugary and delicious oh my god it smells
oh it smells amazing
i do want to taste one
oh oh that's good all right i'm gonna
let this cool down
and then we're gonna go build the boba
drink woohoo
okay so i found a vase that's apparently
supposed to be used in hotel lobbies
around the world
as my boba glass it is 10 inches by 30
inches tall which
in mathematical sense means it's very
big
no alvin there's no pressure you just
can't do it again if you mess it up
let's
first get the boba in oh my god there is
a
don't break there is a huge vertical
distance that this is gonna have to
travel
probably gonna spill everywhere but
that's okay this is really hot
[Music]
oh wow it's like steaming the glass up
you know we don't we don't got to use
the sound for that right we could just
tweak it so we could skip past that part
that's fine
my dream was to have the whole thing a
hundred percent fresh food but
i unfortunately don't have the manpower
and miscalculated a lot of this so i
asked our culinary team
to get some of the fast quick boba i
still wanted it to have the look of a
real bubble milk tea so in this boba
there is a mix
it's not all fresh but i still think
it's going to taste great so please
don't be too mean to me in the comments
but that's what we ended up doing at the
shops they kind of get the brown
sugar drizzle going down the sides kind
of want to emulate that
so we're gonna that's a spill we're
gonna do this
wow this sound is really something else
huh okay it looks kind of cool
i'm pretty into it oh i was gonna tell
you guys a story about how i used to
sell boba back in the day
i was a junior high school kid after
lunch we'd always go get boba
so i thought i could make a lot of money
by also doing it so i
dropped out of chinese school much to
the dismay of my mother
figured out how to make boba at home
went to costco got the big cups
the recipe was exactly the same as this
tea i set up a little table
outside a classroom when the bell rang
the kids came out i
sold it for 250 without boba three
dollars with boba
the kids would buy it made a couple
hundred dollars that summer when i ran
out of boba my mom would actually stay
at home
to cook the boba and drive over a couple
of batches whenever i ran
out but in return she asked for 50
of all proceeds i was like mom that's a
lot of money and she was like
alvin i'm just trying to teach you this
is how life works
she told me that she was actually gonna
save the 50
and put in my bank account later i never
saw that money
ever in my life again she denies all
allegations and has no recollections of
the final amount of money i had
for watching mom all my money back yo
you can't make milk tea without milk so
thanks cows
[Music]
look at that dang
that was pretty cool this is bigger than
my wildest dreams
please hold don't break
so uh i'm gonna find a straw that was
big enough on amazon so i ended up
ordering a clear pvc pipe
i think this is the only thing that will
be usable for
this boba i'll be very careful with this
but here we go
get in there oh it went to the bottom
now
we are going to slowly stir
is it moving i can't tell this
is actually really hard oh my god this
camera is pissing me off up here
slow this is wild oh my god my shoulders
are so tired
[Music]
okay i think that's all the stirring i
can do wow this is the complete finish
thing
this is a lot of bubble i don't even
know how much this weighs i'll have to
do some math later but
i do want my friend inka to see the
final result so i'm going to give her a
call
and just show her what we got what's up
how's it going you want to see the giant
boba that we made
yes show me all right one
two three oh
my god wait is that a straw it's a pvc
pipe
oh my god this is insane that's so much
tea and so much boba
yeah it's uh six gallons of milk uh
22 liters of black tea this is crazy i
love it
congratulations you did it you made it a
giant boba tea
i mean this is your recipe just times
500 probably
enjoy all right
hmm wow this tastes really good
i think this is definitely something you
could serve at a boba shop
and people would buy it so you guys are
probably wondering what's going to
happen with all that boba
i would have loved to share it with my
friends people that i like to see just
because
that's something i like to do with the
show but unfortunately that's just not
something i'm able to do right now so if
excuse me
i have a lot of things to drink i had a
lot of fun today and
i hope you guys had fun watching so i'll
see you guys next time
you